Suppose we have a
rigid body, and it's
rotating about a
fixed axis, and we
know that the angular
acceleration, alpha, is given.
Now, it may be a
function of time.
And we'd like to find
from the angular velocity
and how much angle has
rotated in some time interval.
So the first thing
we have to do is
choose a point in
the rigid body,
and introduce a
coordinate system.
Here we have our angle theta.
And with this point, we have
our r hat and our theta hat
direction.
And recall that by
the right-hand rule,
the k hat is going out of
the plane of the figure.
And so we have our
coordinate system.
And we wrote alpha as the
second derivative of theta
with respect to time k hat.
Now our goal is to
find omega, which
we'll right as the first
derivative of d theta dt k hat,
and also to find theta
as a function of time.
Now recall that our notation
was that alpha z was the omega
z dt equals d squared
theta dt squared.
And in this notation, omega
z was equal to d theta dt.
Now what we're
going to do is we're
going to integrate
alpha, just like we
did in simple circular
motion kinematics
for point-like objects.
And so what we have here is
that for some time interval,
omega z at time t minus
omega z0 is the integral of t
prime equals 0 to
t of alpha z, which
is our component of the
angular acceleration.
We have an integration
variable, dt prime.
And recall that that
implies that omega z t can
have some initial
value at time t
equals 0 plus this
integral relationship,
which is what we want to figure
out by direct integration.
Now, this only works when alpha
z is some function of time.
In order to get the angle,
theta of t, we integrate again,
where we have theta t0
is the integral from t
prime equal 0 to t prime equals
t of this function omega z.
Again, we have some integration
variable, t prime, dt prime.
And so we see that
theta t can have
some initial value plus
this integral relationship,
t prime equals t of
omega z t prime dt prime.
And this is how
we can figure out
how the point p has a
component of angular velocity,
and what angle the
point p sweeps out
in some time interval t.